us-backed Iraqi forces are on a new
offensive to recapture the last Mosul
neighborhood under Isis control the
terror group is using snipers and
suicide car bombers in heavily civilian
areas the battle for the ISIS stronghold
has lasted more than seven months
Charlie d'Agata is with Iraqi forces on
the edge of Mosul's old city covering
what may be the final days of the fight
good morning this is as far as Araki
forces have been able to get towards the
old city as they advance from the south
on the other side of that mound they've
been taking sniper fire now throughout
the weekend we've witnessed as us and
Iraqi artillery heavy weapons and
mortars have been fired into these areas
which came as a surprise to us because
the UN estimates there may be as many as
200,000 civilians that are still trapped
inside the old city and it's getting
more difficult to pinpoint these Isis
targets as they move around these
congested heavily densely populated
areas as they advanced from the south
the north and the West three different
Iraqi forces closing in on the old city
they're making progress and they have
made progress over the weekend but it's
getting slowed as they reach these
narrow streets and alleyways where they
have to hunt down Isis militants we
spoke to American doctors who told us
medics nearby who told us that they're
waiting for a surge of patients after
the people that are inside that old city
who have been undernourished
malnourished and in some cases coming
under fire and explosions collapse
buildings will start pouring out of
there that's the next thing we're
expecting as the Iraqi forces pushing
and close in on this Isis stronghold
there will be a flood of refugees in
desperate need of help for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata Mosul Iraq some
excellent reporting there from Charlie
d'Agata Charlie thank you